Artificial intelligence can now model you
in 3D from a single video,
without fancy camera equipment.
The new system has three stages.
First it analyzes a short video of a person moving
preferably turning around in a circle
for each frame it creates a silhouette
separating the person from the background.
Then, using machine learning techniques
(when a computer learns a task from many examples)
it roughly estimates the 3D body shape
and location of joints
In the second stage,
it “unposes” the virtual human from each frame,
making them all stand with arms out in a T-shape,
and combines these T-posed people
into one more accurate model.
In this study, it had an average accuracy
of about 5 mm.
Finally, in the third stage, it applies color
and texture to the model based on recorded
hair, clothing, and skin.
Now in virtual 3D space,
you can change your clothes or your weight.
Or even perform a perfect pirouette.
No practice necessary.